[Music]
Happy Thanksgiving everyone guys matt is
being so sweet on taking me to Vaughn's
because I'm making some pumpkin bread
today for the festivities he's really
unhappy about it
happy Thanksgiving guys this is so
exciting but now Edie's gonna be joining
us for the adventure because we told him
that there's a Starbucks at Vaughn
[Music]
so I'm pushing it so I can be in the
shop
yes family size watermelon
[Music]
we'll make some pumpkin bread I'm doing
this I'm doing this right get a warm
beverage but do you want to go to
Starbucks no seems like it's no trouble
for Matt right like we end up at
Starbucks all the time together every
video it's like
wait is that can we make our own skip
we're doing that we're doing it oh wait
do my god more ingredients or does it
come with everything it's probably all
in there yep we're gonna make this this
is a great idea we're back got all the
goods Alison has already started
prepping the turkey I wouldn't even know
like what to do with this thing that's a
big boy how long does he take the cook
three hours Wow all right time to make
this pumpkin bread
[Music]
yeah maybe this makes one I really
thought that there was gonna be like a
lot more in here
why would it make something gluten-free
I thought I was just trying to make it a
little stupid Dom don't
[Music]
oh man this is like Stu sure I'll just
put it back in the oven or this is just
like an impossible
I think it's oh man guys this damn
pumpkin I'll beat the top we're gonna go
for a really cool drone shot it's got as
Mavic so I'm pretty excited because this
thing is so incredible I also just
realized half of this video and actually
probably all of yesterday's video I've
been shooting on some sort of weird
setting and it's not the highest quality
setting that this camera can shoot on so
here does it look better hope so ed
what's the plan we're going to a rock
yeah since this Lakes a bit dried up we
can walk out to what was probably a
really beautiful island e looking rock
we're gonna walk right up to it then
climb on top of one of them set this
drone to orbit us it's gonna be so cool
I haven't even done any of the Auto
flight modes I just get so nervous even
though I know they'll be fine I do
pretty much everything myself I feel
like I fly to myself I'm going up this
way guys so my battery's about to die so
I'm basically just gonna let this thing
film until it dies me or the camera
there's a big crevasse here
good oh boy
this is crazy
do you need a hand a helping hand
thank you passing the drone and the
drone is up in the air
[Music]
we got some drone interference and I
almost had to paint stain out of the sky
okay I'm ready to land it I'm getting
land now
[Music]
but we got the drum we're good oh my
gosh back through this hole back through
the hole oh boy State help you look like
you're in Assassin's Creed right now
beauty
[Music]
we're reviewing the drone footage it
looks so sick it's always so much more
rewarding to when you actually fly it
yourself
yeah look how pretty the police setting
looks Allison look so carving I mean
these are they couldn't be more perfect
and this is so festive
this is what we like to call the beauty
boy stur yeah I'm working and staring at
the same time all day for seven
different toys Elise it's like poop now
oh man I gotta try this bread oven
truffle working on this project since
this morning
like I'm not ever good why would I say
you know what this is the time I think
well we don't know I'm talking about
that
this is like this honestly looks like
vomit it's where do those tricks come
from I can't eat that it looks like
trying to make this easier can you fire
whatever okay let's put them back in
here Oh spray my hands don't wanna get
stuck let's just